foreign
this is Kimberly Leonard in the sky
Newsroom now this episode picks up on
investigations that we've heard about
before on the Sky News Daily how your
money moves around Westminster we call
this our Westminster accounts
investigation and our Deputy political
editor Sam coats has an update today on
some of his work particularly about
groups of MPS who do make the news
sometimes research groups like The
European research group The Northern
research group and so on
Sam we need to explain these research
groups before we do anything else really
don't we let the ERG for instance they
would have become pretty familiar to
some people over the years but what
exactly are they
so they're a little curiosity Kimberly
that that Nestles in a sort of
underexamined part of our political
system and this is where under a quirk
that's grown up over decades you could
have bands groups of MPS from the same
party all getting together and what they
do is they as it were subscribed to a
bit of a club and as you say there's a
European research group that's a little
Club on brexit there's a northern
research Group which is a club for Tory
MPS on leveling up there's a socialist
campaign Group which is a kind of fans
of Jeremy corbyn really for members of
the uh for the labor party what they do
is that they can divert a little bit of
their office allowance a couple of
thousand pounds a year maybe a little
bit more of their of the money that goes
to fund their office to a kind of what's
known as a research group to prepare
briefings and basically help them come
up with common positions for instance
the European research group for for many
years now has been doing research about
how to get the kind of the kind of
brexit that would mean the cleanest
break with the European Union and
pushing for that that meant leaving a
single Market leaving the Customs Union
the northern research Group which began
in 2021 under Jake Berry that has been
pushing stuff to do with leveling up and
advancing the agenda of some of those
Northern MPS those red wall MPS that you
saw uh elected when Boris Johnson won
the 2019 general election but here's the
thing Kimberly he's one of the reasons
why why it's quite interesting which is
what these groups end up doing is it
they get some public money in order to
do research but the groups more often
than not end up kind of fronting
squabbles with the leadership whether
it's the ERG that famously kind of was a
key part of the defenestration of
Theresa May or the northern research
Group which has caused trouble for
consecutive Prime Ministers one of the
things we've done is produced the first
ever leaderboard of the amounts of money
that go into these groups in order
essentially to to to support them and
age party has won but but then you've
got the northern research group that's
in this panel we've got 139 000 pounds
of public money the European research
group that's just got under just under a
hundred thousand socialist campaign
groups 67 000 and a a Tory writer sent a
group called The Common Sense Group
which is about six thousand pounds of
public money and it's just a little
under
scrutinized corner of politics but
nevertheless enormously influential I
just think quite a lot of people a lot
of listeners would be surprised that
actually it falls to them to the
taxpayer to support their work given
kind of what they what they spend quite
a lot of time doing and the
investigation focuses on the NRG you
mentioned them the northern research
group so tell us about your
investigation and how that plays into it
this all started because we in the last
set of Westminster accounts um
discovered that people in the northern
research group got donations they got
donations from a northern Broadband
company sort of mid small to mid-sized
Northern Broadband company called IX
Wireless
and basically if you're in the energy
you sort of got this donation of you
know a few thousand pounds and if you
remember back to January people who uh
who saw Westminster accounts won back
then uh you'll have seen me trying to
try to find out why this company was
giving money
um they didn't tell us at the time so I
went and knocked on their door but and
it was just an empty office block it was
all flooded now subsequently i x was
engaged with us and they said that they
gave money to members of the northern
research group in order to support the
northern agenda to support the leveling
up agenda and they thought this was a
good way backing the people in this
group is a good way uh of of doing that
but after doing Westminster account one
I was told by a couple of Tory MPS that
they're a bit nervous about joining up
the northern research group because
there was this conundrum involving
public money money from you know their
office allowance and these donations and
and I didn't really understand what they
were talking about so we got some of
Skies data people to to look into it and
we discovered what what could well be
something of a pattern
which is particularly in 2021 when the
NRG was starting up it it looked or in
several cases it is the it's the case
that you have MPS signing up to the
northern research group actively telling
ipsa the organization that oversees MPS
allowances and expenses to to authorize
payments of two and a half thousand
pounds to to the NRG of that kind of
public money allowance and then two or
three weeks later or in some cases two
or three days later that MP would get
two and a half thousand pounds as a
donation from IX Wireless and there was
just a you know striking correlation
between some of the money that was being
authorized to go from you know the
public person to the NRG with with the
kind of amounts that were coming from
from IX Wireless and I went and talked
to uh some of the MPS something said oh
coincidence no link at all but one of
them said look we knew we knew that if
we signed on the dotted line and joined
the NRG then that we would get a
donation now the question there is is
does that you know would they have
signed up to the NRG if they weren't
getting a donation is is it there for a
proper use of public money all of these
questions being raised but are now going
to be looked at by ipsa that as a result
of looking at the data that underpins
this investigation decided to sort of
open what they call a review it's
basically an investigation into into
what was going on there now we've talked
to Jake Berry the chairman absolutely
denying that there is any link between
the donations and the public money but
as I say I I've talked to you know eight
or MPS remember the northern research
group we say well you know I knew there
was a donation coming that's why I
signed up to it so now there is an
investigation announced today by ipsa
who gonna look into this and you know we
will see uh we will see what they come
up with but it's a it's an it's
interesting because I think the whole
question of public money in this in this
area is as I say not not one that people
have looked at particularly closely
before
Sam could you just give us a just a
little bit of extra context here because
there is a control on what public money
MPS get is in there what what can that
money go on because not everyone will
will know that this case the heart of
why you might want a donation rather
than a little bit of kind of of your
office allowance if you're an if you're
an MP so MPS get paid just under 90 000
pounds but they also have to do all
sorts of things you've got to travel
they've got to run offices they've got
to employ staff the staff have got to
travel all that kind of stuff so they
get a a a handsome sum it's a it's
somewhere around a quarter million
pounds uh it depends a bit where they
are in order to run their offices and as
part of that they they employ staff they
staff can do party political things but
they can also
um basically tick the Box subscribe as
it were to to these groups of uh of sort
of um party political workers doing
research on on individual subjects and
that's that's how that's probably the
most political thing that this money can
be put towards but but essentially where
it's public money it's not meant to be
used for campaigning there are quite
strict controls on what could be done
with it whereas if you get a donation if
you get a campaigning donation from a
businessman or an individual then you're
free to use that uh for however you want
when it comes to to campaigning you
could use that on leaflets you can use
that on billboards you can um you can
basically use that to support your
re-election in essence research is meant
is is something that is regarded as
possible to be publicly funded even if
it's part of political research but
campaigning is not and you need a
donation in order to do in order to do
that which is why in some senses a
donation it's just a much more value
when it comes to uh when it comes to uh
when it comes to being an MP okay Sam
now you said that you've been talking to
Jake Barry so let's have a listen to um
to his explanation
do you have a list of the members of the
NRG because I know you've tried to use
these figures before to say there's
something wrong look I actually think
you're doing a massive disservice at Sky
trashing Northern businesses who want to
support Northern MPS it is completely I
don't know whether you're alleging some
sort of illegality I'm asking I'm asking
questions it is completely wrong when
businesses want to go out and support
Northern MPS who are transforming the
business Community for them for those
businesses then to be trashed in the
media for doing something completely
legal and straightforward and I actually
think if we want to live in a country
where we celebrate business trashing
them for supporting political parties is
is a completely counterproductive thing
to do we're not trashing we're just
asking whether it's whether it's normal
that David Mundell who's a Scottish MP
kind of rooted 2 500 pounds of his
office allowance to the nrj NRG two days
later he gets 2 500 pounds in a donation
from Ike's well people just look at that
and and and and find it odd can you just
explain what's going on there there's no
as I said there is no connection between
your membership and receiving political
donations
[Music]
okay Sam so that was Jake Berry um what
about those private donors what have
they said
so IX Wireless say that they believe in
advancing the lifting up agenda they
believe that basically getting these
donations is a is is the best way uh of
of doing what they want uh and
um it's all within the law and and
completely transparent so
um you know Jake Berry was making the
argument that by focusing on the role of
private donors we're effectively
trashing their reputation in the media
but I think um just looking at what that
money is doing looking at asking why
it's going to places uh and asking who
to benefit beneficiaries on what what
kind of benefits they they get I think
is a is a very valid exercise okay Simon
you say there's an independent
parliamentary standards Authority
investigation how will that play out
right so ipsa which is both the body
that hands out the money to MPS and also
the Watchdog so it does the
investigations if it thinks things are
going wrong now they we shared with them
the data underlying our investigation
and in response they put out a quite
frankly pretty Punchy statement Titan
Westminster jargon so I'll Trend I'll
read a bit and translate it for you they
say in light of research bicycle news
ipsa has started an assurance review
that's an investigation basically to
assess whether the northern research
group has contravened the rules
surrounding direct payment of
subscriptions from MP's business cost
budgets so did members of the northern
research Group by the way in which they
signed up to the northern research group
now then it says ipsa's rematch is the
use of taxpayer funding not the receipt
of other sources of income by MPS and
there's therefore informed the office of
the Parliamentary commissioner for
standards of his actions now what that
means is that ipsa only does public
money that it Doles out that's the only
thing it really looks at and then when
it comes to donations from external
sources a different investigate dating
body has to get involved and that's the
Parliamentary Commission of standards
and so ipsa has basically told the
commissioner for standards look out I'm
doing an investigation I may end up
coming back to you if I think there's
something that you need to know at the
end of it and then it also says ipsa
will also conduct really jargonese this
assurance reviews of the other new
pooled services to check that they were
meeting the requirements of ipsa funding
which they commit to in writing and the
rules regarding pooled Services now that
is jug and heavy I hope your eyelids
didn't slightly start to close what that
means is they're not just looking at the
northern research group but because
there's this proliferation of research
groups the Socialist one the uh uh the
um and so on uh that you then they're
actually going to have a little look at
all of the new ones that doesn't include
by the way the European research Group
which which actually is more than more
than a decade old it predates ipsa and
they've been these reviews into the ERG
before and uh pretty much the erg's come
out with a clean bill of health so uh
these new ones the ones that are going
to get the kind of uh the microscope
taken out and add a little look at what
they're doing okay Sam and just quickly
before you go can you explain the next
part of this investigation it's going to
be all across Sky News on Friday it
focuses on MP's second jobs doesn't it
that's right so what we've done quite a
lot of the Westminster cats project is
in conjunction with tortoise the media
company and what they've done is they've
gone through and basically
um scraped all the hours that MPS have
to say that they work when they're doing
a second job and put them in one of our
spreadsheets they put them on our
database accessible to everybody on the
scurney's website uh and we've just done
a bit of data analysis about how many
hours MPS say that they're working
outside of their uh at their troll uh
We've looked at the average hour hourly
rate uh what you know what price your mp
uh per hour uh and uh who's at the top
of the leaderboard that's all coming on
Friday okay fantastic thanks a lot Sam
this episode was produced by Sola
operation the editor was Paul stanworth
[Music]